tu crois que les super héros victorieux
cette publicité meetic n'a que 15 ans
pourtant on dirait que c'était dans un
autre siècle muscu sauf sur le consoler
et oui en surf partout tout le temps au
restaurant seul ou avec d'autres
on dirait que le cellulaire s'est rendu
un accessoire comme une paire de
souliers comme comme une culotte
pratiquement wa j'ai pu me soulage suite
ou me pour essayer de redonner ne serait
ce que l'espace de quelques heures ces
lettres de noblesse une conversation en
tête à tête
jacques gaspo a inventé un jeu offert
les lundis sans cellulaire ou ce que les
gens qu'ils arrivent une police à la
porte qui leur donne 3 $ de la belle et
la bête
et si on les attrape éclaircies l'avons
allait 20 $ à la fois c'est une occasion
pour essayer de revivre les relations
humaines quoi
les 75% ce pour attraper ces terres se
sait sortir des remous
il ya des informations ou par le chili x
on n'a pas le temps de jouer à la police
et la politique est stricte les
cellulaires reste au vestiaire ses
débuts avec tes amis ghapan risque
quelqu'un propres photos permettent en
rien être sur facebook instagram quand
les gens dansent ils ne ratent pas rater
une si müller s'amusent ils parlent
entre eux vous avez vu ses dirigeants
dans une catégorie dense en regardant la
saignée et oui ça arrive toujours le
moment ça m'énervait
donc j'ai dit j'ouvre un bar qui
confisque les téléphones cellulaires des
gens coup de marketing ou tendance la
prise de conscience de la nuisance que
constitue le cellulaire à l'esprit
grégaire et dans l'air du temps
argenteuil en bulgarie la marque de
bières amstel a distribué des casiers
cellulaire dans les bars
elle offre une bière gratuite si vous
laissez votre appareil
hassan par l'eau au brésil une autre
marque de bière encourage la
convivialité en donnant à ses clients
une glacière muni d'une technologie
jusque là utilisées qu'en prison pour
priver les détenus de la possibilité de
communiquer elle coupe les ondes
cellulaires dame kit kat à installer des
angles sans réseau sans fil pour que les
gens puissent lire un journal papier
penser rêver et même par grand beau sur
le salon thé camellia sinensis à
montréal est un des pionniers du no
techno et on peut témoigner ici qu'il
est possible d'être prospère sans
cellulaire les jaunes c'est leur nom
souvent pour 7 pour cette zone
tranquille son techno et on a les files
d'attentes pour les gens qui veulent
expérience ironique en effet des files
d'attentes pour échapper à la tyrannie
sans fil émilie dubreuil radio canada
montréal